hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm javi kawaii so today we're gonna
review Creed we just saw it about 20
minutes ago what did you think I really
liked it I liked it a lot I thought it
was slow at times but overall I thought
it was really really good
I thought it paid homage to the original
Rocky's in an interesting way while
updating it with modern music I guess
yeah they took the character of Adonis
Creed and made him different you know
like it wasn't like you're watching a
pod it wasn't like you're watching a
previous Rocky character at all I like
how it starts off where you see that
this kid went to juvie he's like the son
of Apollo Creed out of wedlock so he's
like the bastard child but rather than
making it like something were you really
pity the guy because his performance
wasn't like feel sorry for me it was a
rather human strong and vulnerable
performance that I naturally cared for
the guy rather than like oh look at the
writing trying to make it feel a little
sympathetic for him well that's the
thing about Rocky movies in general even
if even the ones you don't like they
always tend to have heart in them that
is what certainly came through on this
one I thought that it had a lot of heart
by the end of the film I'm like wow I
really this moved me this yeah this
touched me in a way that I wasn't
expecting I thought it was beautiful
I liked I felt like really good by the
time this movie was over I wasn't
expecting to like it as much as I did I
didn't think it was gonna be the pacing
that it was even the angles that they
were doing it felt very classical in the
style that it was being shot it didn't
feel like it was overly done like a
Michael Bay film or something like that
it felt like it took its time to just be
a real Rakeem yeah and even though it's
captured darker than most Rocky movies I
wouldn't call this a dark film the end
of the day it's like it's darker than a
typical rocky film but it's not like a
super gritty dark what do you mean by
dark what anybody doesn't well when I
saw the trailers I thought this was
gonna be like that really raw hardcore
realistic like depressing kind of rocky
film but it wasn't that at all right
there was some real drama in there and
there was some there's a lot of
believable drama to stuff the characters
have to go through the obstacles they
have to overcome internally that's one
of my favorite things about this
franchise is it's always goes back to
like
your mentality who you are at heart and
you know really you are your own worst
enemy and you got to go against yourself
there there's a lot of like successful
themes that I think are more applicable
than just the fighting world rocky at
one point even says it like I believe
this is true and fighting and I believe
this is true in life you see these
characters really grow through the
process of training and everything and
all the philosophies that Adonis Creed
has to learn along the way yeah I like
that they include life philosophies for
you to take with you as an audience ago
hmm I like that it's it for thought it's
inspiring it's like actually inspiring
and I gotta say Michael B Jordan by the
time this movie was done you know like
I've been hearing so many critics say
like Stallone should get an Oscar
nomination but a lot of time as fun was
then I was like Michael B Jordan should
be getting consideration he committed
like the emotions even there's one scene
where he does cry you could see that
he's fighting against the tears and I
like a good crime scene like that yeah
you know like you could do the Academy
Award breakdown performance but I also
like it when you're trying to fight it
yeah in real life you we usually try to
fight tears and this kind of character
is the kind of guy who would fight tears
and I feel like that's a hard place for
an actor to get to yeah because you know
a lot of times actors will struggle with
the ability to just cry to actually be
have to be able to cry but then also
hold it back you know what I felt this
like though not enough robots no no we
need I don't know what happened to that
I mean we were in the future at one
point in rocky for them and all that
I like how they used the I guess the
lore so to speak of the previous rocky
films to kind of influence the storyline
in here they managed to do it in such a
way that that just abandon all the hokey
Ness yeah of the previous films of the
pearl like rocky 4 for instance and the
robot like we just mentioned I thought
they did a great job of just making it
feel grounded again yeah as opposed like
rocky one it felt like it went right
back to its roots I thought that Rocky
5x Rocky Balboa I thought they did a
good job with six you know or six sorry
I thought they did a good job with that
one too and that felt grounded as well I
think this is like following following
stylistically with that film yeah and
even updating it further it obviously
has a more modern-day relatable heart I
didn't like the romance in this film I
like the romance but it didn't always
keep my inch
it was definitely wasn't like rocky and
Adrian like this was something that
seemed like rather familiar like I've
seen it in other movies before a romance
like that but their chemistry was good
and there was some realistic moments
that I liked between the two but I
wasn't always hooked by it I just didn't
see how it really enhanced the film I
thought that it would if you took that
out you the film would've been twenty
minutes shorter and a lot better for him
yeah I didn't think he needed as
emphasis as much as they did at the same
time I liked how she was more than just
a plot device like she seemed like an
actual character if that makes anything
you know you don't even oh no I don't
want takes to the ring yeah I just
didn't care for her I mean I thought she
was a good actress I thought she was
really pretty it wasn't I didn't feel it
the only scene I liked was when he was a
beatboxing or not B bucks but like
rapping ya on the fly and he's like what
happened to the beat
look at his no but that's what I mean is
I felt their interaction felt very real
to me
like it didn't seem like they were
performing at all like I thought that
they had real chemistry
I like black love black glow yeah I like
watching two black people all together
you know actually I was thinking about
that that you don't see I remember mom
was it there was a spike Lee movie that
came out years ago and I remember black
audience is like felt so emotional at
seeing two black characters kiss on
screen because you never saw it and
actually you still don't see it a whole
lot even today
two black characters kiss or make love
or anything like that and that was one
thing I did appreciate it about this
film it's like it just it was just a
normal thing and yeah you know it didn't
make a big deal out of it they'd ever
had to point out that there were black
characters right you know and I feel
like in movies especially nowadays they
will point it out especially if the lead
characters black they pointed out that
Rocky's white I didn't know that that's
about as far as it went oh I didn't know
Rocky was white he's Italian I thought
he was Mexican
are you lying no you're not lying you
thought he was Maxie no I'm just kidding
the Italian stallion Howie I don't know
your brain might not process there's one
thing that's always really interesting
to me is even into crappy Rocky films
rocky still is a like he has grown in
some way he has changed in some way
based off the events of the previous
film after watching Rocky Balboa I was
like
how are we gonna make older Iraqi
different and I did like what Stallone
did with this performance Ally you know
it's cool that he didn't write the film
and I felt like he even brought a
stronger performance you're not having
written the film himself yeah he lends a
certain authenticity to it that you
don't see another Sylvester Stallone
move now that's the weird thing about it
like he feels so genuine and real I'm
like wow I I believe you Stallone you
are so real right now they created this
Adonis Creed character who I really
liked a lot like I wasn't watching it
going when the hell are they gonna cut
back to Rocky can we get back to Rocky
please all the scenes with Rocky really
enjoyed Stallone's performance is
fantastic in this film he has some great
really like emotional like another part
that's where him and Creed are similar
where there's another scene where you
can tell Stallone is fighting back like
emotion and stuff like I don't want to
give anything away but there are some
great scenes with with rocky and where
they take his character like he's he's
back to being 100% truly alone in this
film there's no Adrian there's no Paulie
and now all he has is this kid who is
looking after now but you really get the
sense that Rocky is just super caring
loving guy that he's not using this kid
to fulfill some void or something like
you could see that he really is just
giving his full heart to him you know
there's a lot to be said about the
sequel that hasn't been jazzed up to be
crazy kind of like Robocop or Terminator
Genisys it falls in line with what that
was established at the beginning we kind
of went over that a little bit already
but I think there's a lot to be said for
that because everything else that's
doing a sequel tries to update it to
2015 and make it super crazy and hyper
and like MT yeah kind of fulfillment
whereas this was like nope we're gonna
just stick to the rhythm of the first
film and I'm so drama
there was a great authenticity and I
gotta say Michael B Jordan like from an
athletic point of view whoa holy crap
like beyond getting like a really in
shape body you're watching this guy
throw punches yeah you're like this dude
can really box like it's insane watching
him like even when he's just shadow
boxing you're like damn he's so [ __ ]
fast it's like how does he do it his
first like actual real fight scene in
the film the one in the middle of the
movie I thought that was awesome that
was
instantly one of my favorite shots of
all time I was like wow I cannot believe
they're actually doing this yeah the
entire fight
there's one shot even when they would
like ring the bell and then rocky would
go to the corner to coach him a little
bit they still kept it in one shot even
there might have been some editing
tricks I don't know regardless the
evolution of it the hits looked real ya
know it's like to coordinate all that
stuff just blew my frickin mind away I'm
like cuz the cameras moving around and
why not and then when I'm making contact
it looks so legitimate the sound effects
are obviously helping but you could see
in other Rocky movies yeah where it's
just clearly missing yeah
whereas this was it just felt like it
was really well crowd fights in here
felt very much more authentic than the
other Rocky films - it felt real first
off it did bring back that vibe that I
loved from the first rocky of whenever
our main character lands a hit you feel
that whenever he gets it you're like ah
[ __ ] I like feeling that again where the
last fight didn't feel like oh you know
still there were some really stylish
shots in there as well sometimes
sometimes regardless though I I still
felt the emotional impact of this
character in this fight and there was
even one moment where he just has a
little exchange of dialogue that kind of
made me want to tear up a little bit in
the middle of the fight when he's trying
to tell rocky why he has to do this
there are so many strong character
moments and the relationship and the
chemistry between Michael B Jordan and
Sylvester Stallone was so good like you
can see why these two love each other it
was so authentic and I felt like
Stallone didn't have any judgement or
intimidation over this guy even off set
like I get this vibe that they probably
just really got along I so the only two
things I didn't like about the film was
the romance and every time it
superimposed a profile of a boxer like
whenever they gave like the stats yeah
of them I was like why are you doing
that like I would have felt the impact
of those moments without that they're
just the same if anything it's
detracting from my ability to immerse
myself in those moments really I didn't
do that for me I saw from his point of
view like I saw that every time it dawn
is saw like one of these boxers it was
him remembering all their stats I felt
like that was an audience thing like
here's why it's important all we see we
need to learn to why these boxers are
threatened
sometimes I guess so I'm sure there
could have been a more subtle way to
handle it rather than stopping the movie
and telling you with words one thing I
always that bothered me about the Rocky
fights was well we were just mainly with
rocky in general as he didn't know how
to block yeah and in this film like the
boxing matches look more realistic like
those punches that they land like you
were saying earlier look like they're
really getting hit
yeah fight choreography was really good
there's actually blocks in there and
ducks and stuff right and a lot of
uppercuts actually that looks painful
there were great Oh Maj is here and
they're in the film that wasn't so
in-your-face right like hey you remember
Rocky
they would tweak the music here and
there they would use some moments and
there's some familiar areas where they
were they shot and like even with like
him having to grab the chicken like in
Rocky - I was watching this going wow
you don't have to see the previous Rocky
films like you could just watch this
film and Jake and I I didn't think about
that it is interesting that there was no
point in the film whatsoever where I was
like remember when we did this last time
not great uh-huh yeah it felt authentic
it felt like it did its own thing and
yeah you're right you don't have to see
the previous one today it's
self-contained is what you're trying
yeah I think I think it was great I
think it's one of the best movies I've
seen all years definitely one of the
best dramas I've seen all year I think
it's a great addition to the sports
genre - I think what you said there is
key that it's a drama yeah because it's
important to know that going in that
Rocky is a drama
it wasn't best for the first one won
Best Picture and they did not turn it
into an action film yeah I know I keep
saying that but that's like really
important to me because there's only a
few boxing scenes there's just just a
few but right but what makes them
powerful is all the trauma which is most
of the movie the emotional content it's
it's not mainly just him training in him
fighting like there's a lot of other
stuff that goes on with this film yeah
the deeper dynamics of these characters
yeah I really enjoyed it I hope he gets
at least Golden Globe consideration for
stuff anyway um we need a rating I give
it four I give it five out of five
knockouts
that's okay um I give it a something we
talked about the rating system and
you're supposed to be a lot more pro
about it wait what okay yes I give it
five out of five knockouts that's what
that's mu come on
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can click this button and subscribe
to the real rejects chebika way has a
channel you should check that out kind
of similar to this one so you'll enjoy
it too and you can follow us on our
social networks because if we get enough
followers we can get more product
placement because money is the root of
all happiness yes